THE FIRE IS 8% CONTAINED AUTO
LOOK AT YOUR HEADLINES.
SEND TO YOU.
STEVE: ANTHONY FAUCI GROWING
CALLS FROM REPUBLICANS TO BE
FIRED AFTER NEW DOCUMENTS
SUGGEST HE MAY HAVE LIED ABOUT
U.S. SUPPORT FOR GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH WHEN HE HAD
THIS BACK AND FORTH.
>> , THE NIH DOES NOT EVER AND
DOES NOT NOW FUND GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH IN THE WUHAN
INSTITUTE.
>> GOVERNMENT SCIENTISTS LIKE
YOURSELF WHO FAVOR GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH --
>> -- I DON’T FAVOR GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH IN CHINA.
YOU ARE SAYING THINGS THAT ARE
NOT CORRECT.
STEVE: BUT, NEW REPORTING FROM
THE INTERCEPT IS REIGNITING
QUESTIONS ABOUT COVID ORIGINS
AND THE LABS IN CHINA.
NICHOLAS WADE IS A FORMER
INVESTIGATIVE SCIENCE REPORTER
FOR THE "NEW YORK TIMES," HE
JOINS US NOW.
NICHOLAS, GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
STEVE: WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE HUNDRED PAGES THE INTER
SEPTEMBER WAS ABLE TO GET IT
SURE LOOKS LIKE THAT LAB WAS WE
HELPED FUND.
>> CERTAINLY WAS.
TAKING VIRUSES RELATED TO THE
SARS FAMILY OF VIRUSES.
THEY WERE STICKING INTO THEM THE
SPIKE PROTEIN GENES AND OTHER
VIRUSES AND GETTING THEM TO
INFECT HUMANIZED MICE AS IT’S
CALLED AND SHARING THE NEW VICES
THEY CREATED MORE THAN THE
VIRUSES THEY CAME FROM.
THAT’S THE STANDING DEFINITION
OF GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH.
STEVE: RIGHT.
SO WHEN FAUCI HAS BEEN UP ON
CAPITOL HILL, PARTICULARLY
SPARRING WITH RAND PAUL, HE SAID
WE NEVER DID THAT.
BUT WHEN YOU LISTEN TO TO HIM, I
SOUNDS LIKE THE LAWYERS AT THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTES OF HEALTH
HAVE SAID, OKAY.
WE’RE GOING TO DEFINE IT AS
SOMETHING OVER HERE AND YOU
CAN -- YOU WILL BE LEGITIMATE IN
SAYING THIS, DR. FAUCI.
AND IT JUST SOUNDS LIKE HE IS
HIDING BEHIND LEGAL LEGAL WE SEL
GET AWAY WITH SOMETHING IT LOOKS
LIKE WE DNCHTS YOU ARE EXACTLY
RIGHT.
GAIN OF FUNCTION RESEARCH IS A
VERY HARD THING TO DEFINE THERE
HAVE BEEN VARYING DEFINITIONS OF
IT OVER TIME.
SO I THINK DR. FAUCI HAS ONE IN
MIND HE THINKS IS DEFENSIBLE.
I WISH HE WOULD EXPLAIN WHAT IT
WAS BECAUSE IT’S NOT TERRIBLY
CLEAR.
STEVE: A UNOF IN REPUBLICANS,
NICHOLAS, SUGGEST BECAUSE HE
LIED TO CONGRESS HE SHOULD GO.
THE JOE BIDEN HAS MADE IT VERY
CLEAR UNDER NO CIRCUMSTANCES
WOULD THEY EVER FIRE DR. FAUCI.
IS HE TOO BIG TO FIRE
APPARENTLY.
>> WHAT I’M ASTOUNDED BY THIS IS
PROBABLY ABOVE MY PAY GRADE I
WOULD REGARD HIM AS A LONG TIME
PUBLIC SERVANT.
HE HAS A VERY DIFFICULT JOB.
HE HAS SERVED WITH INTEGRITY HE
DOES THE BEST HE CAN I AM
PUZZLED BY HIS BEHAVIOR ON THIS
PARTICULAR INSTANCE OF THE WUHAN
GRANT.
I WISH HE WOULD BE MORE
FORTHCOMING.
I WISH HE WOULD EXPLAIN AS WE
HAVE DISCUSSED EXACTLY WHY IT
WAS NOT GAIN OF FUNCTION
RESEARCH.
I WISH HE WOULD TELL US WHY HE
REJECTED THE INITIAL REPORT BACK
IN JANUARY OF 2020 FROM A GROUP
OF EXPERT VIROLOGY JUSTS THAT
THEY THOUGHT THIS VIRUS WAS MAN
MADE.
THERE ARE LOTS OF THINGS THAT HE
HAS YET TO TELL US BUT HE HAS
GONE INTO STONEWALL MODE ON THIS
INSTANT AND I WISH HE WOULD JUST
TELL US MORE.
STEVE: ABSOLUTELY.
651,000 AMERICANS HAVE DIED.
I THINK WE ARE OWED AN
EXPLANATION BY OUR GOVERNMENT IF
THE GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY KNOWS
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> I WOULD SAY SO.
THE GOVERNMENT MAY NOT KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED BUT IT
CERTAINLY HAS LOTS OF
INFORMATION.
ALL THE INFORMATION IN THE
DOCUMENTS RELEASED YESTERDAY BY
THE INTERCEPT, ALL OF THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY USEFUL IF
THE GOVERNMENT HAD RELEASED IT
IN JANUARY 2020.
THE WHOLE INVESTIGATION INTO THE
VIRUS ORIGINS MIGHT HAVE TAKEN A
VERY DIFFERENT TURN.